well smelly hates me a for going so
close to the sideline and I said some I
said I said well you know you've gotta
I've always been told you got to get as
close as you can to that post for your
kicker and I knew Renee was cooking it
so I was like okay she's just sitting me
up here I need to get as far in as I can
so she can get the kick and I'm so good
because yeah I nearly ran out I I knew I
knew with a beautiful line was how close
were you I didn't notice you being close
and smelly he replied it he kept
replaying it to me and he was like look
at your foot look at your foot I'm like
yeah yeah
and the worst thing is is Renee missed
the kick so I was like
[Laughter]